le chef du colonel qui est face à lui et
c'est parce que le colonel a été au
combat et a donné sa vie dans ce combat
que le chef des armées est là pour
rendre reconnaissance à ce soldat voilà
le chef de l'état est arrivé qui arrive
donc directement son véhicule arrive
directement dans cette cour des
invalides un emmanuel mâcon qui est
accompagné de son épouse brigitte macron
qui est donc à ses côtés pour cette
cérémonie
vous voyez il salue edouard philippe
le premier ministre le ministre de
l'intérieur gérard collomb et florence
parly la ministre des armées le général
elle commenté la suite le coin que le
chef d'état major des armées le chef
d'état major particulier du président le
directeur général de la gendarmerie avec
lequel il entretient tout
particulièrement puisque c'est son
subordonné direct
et ensuite viendra le gouverneur
militaire de paris donc qui est celui
qui a un petit peu organisé puisque tout
ceci est sous sa responsabilité avec le
directeur général de la gendarmerie
ensuite le chef de l'état va
probablement aller saluer tous les
drapeaux
[Musique]
je
il
[Musique]